last night on 60 minutes president Trump
expressed skepticism about climate
change to lesley stahl days after the
United Nations issued an alarming new
scientific study on global warming
at the same time NASA is winding down
its operation IceBridge that mission
flies planes to Antarctica from South
America to study ice melt for the latest
installment in our climate Diaries
series Mark Phillips took two of those
flights and he joined us joins us now
from Punta Arenas Chile mark good
morning
good morning from Punta Arenas at the
southern tip of South America and a
place with a 500 year history of
scientific exploration standing on a
replica of the ship that Ferdinand
Magellan used on the first-ever
round-the-world voyage which came
through these waters that there is HMS
Beagle a replica of the ship Charles
Darwin sailed on also through here but
Punta Arenas has never seen anything
like what NASA is doing now it can seem
like flying across the surface of a
distant Frozen Planet which you might
expect from NASA 21-7 with you but this
flight is just 1,500 feet above the most
remote place on earth Antarctica where
the frozen wastes are becoming less
frozen all the time as mission scientist
John Sonntag says they're not here for
the view and the race basically we need
to know what's happening to to the
climate and specifically to sea level
and a lot of what's happening to sea
level starts at home and that's that's
when that ice is either liberated or
sequestered that's right
for a decade this time of year NASA has
been flying to Antarctica out of Punta
Arenas we'll say till 6:15 p.m. 25
minutes now using a 50 year old dc-8
jammed with high-tech equipment and
highly trained scientists the world's
hottest climate science in the world's
coldest place it may look like just snow
and ice to the ice after year and that
yardstick is not only finding less ice
it's finding that the ice melting is
speeding up research stations on the
ground can see the ice loss but to get
the big picture you've got to get up
here says missions chief scientist Joel
McGregor years presently the Antarctic
Ice Sheet is discharging more than two
Olympic sized swimming pools worth of
what into the ocean every second at that
rate and arctica alone could cause as
much as 6 inches of sea-level rise this
century then that's a clear concern for
coastal communities not just the United
States but coastal countries around the
world
why has the melting increased that's the
word II Ice Sheet down there warming
seas have turned a thick solid sheet of
ice attached to the coast into a
collection of icebergs linked by a thin
film of ice and that's allowed the
massive Fleming glacier behind it to
flow into the ocean at least twice as
quickly there's an ice shelf it
disintegrates then what happens then
what happens is that the cork is out of
the bottle and the ice can accelerate
for a while what used to seem so frozen
and so permanent is now fluid and
changing fast
after the science of course comes the
politics the question for the scientists
is is anybody listening and that's the
subject of the next of the series of
climate Diaries Gale which we'll do
tomorrow
well we're listening thank you very much
Mark Phillips